let's just bring you some breaking news
that's coming in there this is in the
cage regarding rebecca vardy and colleen
rooney and the latest the decision
that's just coming is that rebecca vardy
has lost the wagatha christie high court
libel battle that she brought against
colleen rooney over a viral social media
post so that is that colleen rooney has
won and rebecca vardy has lost that
libel battle that she brought against um
colleen rooney now if you remember this
case began with an online spats before
heading to the courts for a legal fight
which of course has cost millions of
pounds now it was back in may um this
year that um
mrs vardy and colleen rooney actually
came face to face in court and the trial
lasted for a week of course then since
then we have been awaiting that decision
that decision was due to come out at
midday and at midday on the dot we
appear to have had those results that
are results then coming in from the
court so the latest that we are hearing
is that rebecca vardy has lost the high
court libel battle that she brought
against colleen rooney over a viral
social media post so
the latest um coming in there now if you
also remember this started actually back
in october of 2019
if you remember and this was through a
very famous well now famous um instagram
post which colleen rooney actually then
accused rebecca vardy of leaking what
she described as false stories about her
private life to the press
and it was dubbed regather christie back
then of course looking at the wives and
girlfriends wag that name and of course
in the way that colleen barini went on
to
reveal um that um the person
who revealed that which of course she
accused rebecca vardy of doing well
let's cross now live to the high courts
in central london and we can go now to
sky's either bennett's and either what's
been the reaction then to this then so
um rebecca vardy then losing that libel
trial that she brought against colleen
rooney
i'm surprised that is the reaction here
among legal experts and journalists i
think everyone was actually thinking
rebecca vardy might win because i think
there was quite a quite a
a lot of work that uh
colleen rooney's lawyers had to do to
prove that the claim was substantially
true
that
the leak did come not just from rebecca
vardy's account but also uh rebecca
vardy herself
so i've got the summary here that i'll
read you and this is i'm seeing it for
the first time so i'll read you um
through it as i as i go um so the first
paragraph this is from mrs justice stain
the court has handed down judgment in
this libel action today
um the claim has been dismissed the
defendant succeeded in establishing that
the essence of the libel was
substantially true the defendant's
alternative defense of publication in
the public interest was rejected so she
had two grounds for defense one that the
claim was true and secondly that it was
in the public interest so and she only
actually had to win on one of those
grounds she has done the judge has
deemed that the uh the claim was
substantially true
the court observed
some members of the public have
responded to the revealed post by
subjecting mizvahdi to vile abuse
including messages wishing her her
family and even
then unborn baby ill in the most awful
ways nothing of which ms vadi has been
accused nor any of the findings in this
judgment provide any justification or
excuse for subjecting her or her family
or any other person involved in this
case to such vitriol now um the claim
all goes back to this uh post by uh
clean rooney uh wife and former england
captain wayne rooney in october 2019 in
which she publicly accused fellow
footballer's wife rebecca vardy of
giving the sun newspaper false stories
about her
stories
and that was that was after some death
detective work on her part she
planted fake stories about herself on
her instagram account
made them only visible to rebecca
vardy's account because she suspected
she was behind those leaks
and then when they appeared in the sun
newspaper she there were three stories
she had what she claimed then was a
smoking gun she she posted this reveal
post that the court
uh refers to there with this famous
ellipses saying it's rebecca vardy's
account it went viral online and then
resulted in this two week long libel
battle and because vardy uh claimed that
she was not behind the leaks um ev any
uh what's that messages she exchanged
with her agent ms what had been
destroyed or lost in the north sea a
phone was lost in the north sea
and then we had this two week long legal
battle in which we heard about all sorts
ranging from um rooney's marriage
difficulties with husband wayne to
to vardy's relationship formal
relationship with the pop star peter
andre
as i say surprise is the overall
reaction from legal experts here that
rooney has won
so no damages will be paid the legal
fees in all of this are astronomical
stretching well into the millions
which does beg the question why both
parties did pursue this route and not
any settlement outside of court but we
do now have a
conclusion to this long-running
legal saga